he's Roger Bennett who joins us now and
a new book encyclopedia blazer Tanika is
that correct
indeed it's the 50 shades of gray of all
generation you can find men in Blazers
TV show on NBCSN the podcast lives on
iTunes Spotify SoundCloud all major
podcasting apps where is the World Cup
fever right now here in the United
States it's a low great book I mean I've
seen questions or I see and I just want
to salute over there it's not often it's
not often we are in the presence of
comedy genius and to sit here and just
look at you over there the Michelle wolf
of our generation would you like to hear
a clue is killer yes Ritchie last night
oh my why did they came here to talk
about my book and the tour that we're
about to enter Tate you in the world no
no I'm here alright fritzy to see the
joke here we go here we go here's the
clip from fritzy just a portion of last
night 7 minutes and 37 seconds how
difficult is to find your seats and a
concert or a sporting event think about
it it's got all the information you need
right there on the ticket section row
seat number section row C number it's
really really not that complicated I've
got these people coming over to me and
saying I think we're in the same thing
not only they not to end my seats
they're all the way on the other side of
they couldn't have been further from
where I'm at so I don't understand
section row seat let's let's get it
together okay that oh that was the joke
no that's the sound last night there was
one person they didn't get it they
didn't get it he's ahead of where the
comedy audience are in America right now
cuz I got it I got it I got it it's like
an Andy Kaufman s performance art thing
where frets II went to Caroline's and
did a seven-minute performance which
encapsulated the US Men's National Team
attempt to qualify for the World Cup in
2018
they failed he was pretending the US did
fail so to answer your question where is
the World Cup fever
it's a low-grade fever though because
the u.s. men and I wonder hat what
what percentage of the population in
America actually know this yeah my
breaking news on your show the u.s. did
not qualify for the World Cup which
starts on June the 14th I think on June
the 14th many Americans maybe 80% will
wake up and say what's with that bro yo
where's the nit of the circuit thing I
mean so we didn't qualify and because of
that right now
it's a low-grade fever but I tell you
Americans love a big circus they love a
circus they love an excuse to cut work
on mass and daytime drink out the
cubicles for 31-day savoring the
worldcat when the World Cup comes in
Russia
yes rogue state Russia has the worldcat
well done FIFA when that happens that
America will be there you will but who
are we going who should we root for so
many I mean I want a fun team what are
we rooting for in our book could be
encyclopedia blazer Tanika is the it's
designed as your companion for your to
enhance your viewing pleasure because
Americans will watch this World Cup they
love they love the World Cup circus
it's a telenovela really what what
you're rooting for is oh the humanity
you will see heroes forge that giant
Eclipse kind of straight the world at
the same time for 31 days in which
heroes have formed villains humiliate
themselves kind of nations rise up other
nations crumby of me somebody to root
for anybody but England
anybody but England because that is just
like you guys my scar for the
rubbernecking and the crashes you guys
aren't any good oh wait we are so full
of self-loathing Wiest have an empire we
used to have an empire we the better
shape
England soccer or us Asia USA soccer USA
so foul every week I moved here in 1993
and I watched your soccer players take
to the field ginger of beard stone
washed denim of Jersey we write about it
in the book just mullets everywhere
popping off those mullet Alexi Lalas
yellow lesson we they had no baby was
like the Reservoir Dogs see when they
leave the diner they're just swag going
on the like world yeah we put a
Starbucks on every corner yeah we put a
man on the moon we'll cut we'll take it
and that what America has that the
England is lost totally is it is a
belief is a belief that they're going to
win it English they pawned that that we
put on the national team jersey and you
see
in sports you see it all the time in
Americans some teams put the jersey on
and run through walls roll tide you see
other teams put on the jersey and it's
his heaviest chainmail and the history
waves and down England they just want to
go off the field and not be the
scapegoat that's winning the World Cup
for those photos you got Brazil
you've got Germany you've got Spain
you've got Ronaldo the preening show
pony
the Portuguese that Dada LeBron going up
against the Steph Curry Leo Messi we
write about in the book you know he
looks like he's wandered out of
Supercuts on Broadway looks like a bust
a video clip you walk in you're like
you're like where's the Spanish movies
bro when he takes it doesn't even look
over the Village Voice she's just like
second on earth man but he's that tiny
little man who is able to do things and
no other human in sports has ever done
though for them wanting to be the goat
leading Argentina three finals in their
last tournament three losses tears each
time this is what it sounds like when
doves cry
that's what printers Ryan about Lionel
Messi losing him Messi Ronaldo going
against each other it's it it's the kind
of it's a kind of goat conversation that
all of you have debate weekend weekend
by the way home there was well done
right there's a comedy genius would you
rather have Messi's life or Renaldo's
life that is a phenomenal question
Michael Davis if he was here would
probably go the Renaldo way you know
Ronaldo is a man and there's many in the
American sporting pantheon who have kind
of fingers in Ronaldo who seems to only
want to score goals the point of
football win games the point of sport
but purely as a means to an end
so they can take off his jersey and
three the nettle the Portuguese nipple
and show the world not his six-pack but
his eight pack so that lay it's it's a
fascinating way to live life and he does
it I say as a potent athlete like this
is Babe Ruth's pointing to the bleachers
hitting the ball out again and again and
again she can't hate him because
ultimately he is backs up the words you
see are Tom Brady we have real hair with
real hair
yeah you know what is he the Tom Brady
he's more vocal he's more you know I
watched Tom Brady and you see him kind
of try and put himself out there into
the endorsement well Tom Brady does not
seem to enjoy doing the doing the
endorse a try now they I think prefers
the endorsements the being oiled I want
to moved into Renaldo's Roo in the
Portuguese team hotel just after they
left in Donetsk in 2012 in Ukraine
it took me seven months to get the Drac
Anwar smell he's in me he's in a man Lee
seems like a Paco Rabanne type of guy
with Kalon I think you overestimate him
i overestimated my knowledge do sell a
Ronaldo pack of beer Oh a six-pack there
would be an eight pack but imagine if
you just had his abs yes so the top of
the cans yes were the ABS of Ronaldo
that would be a six-pack of Ronaldo that
would be and when you opened it would
taste like I won the leo messi life to
be candid Lionel Messi is a gentleman
who is so unassuming I mean the the kind
of athlete who's the American parallel a
guy that just does it over and over
again the sublime the only picks the
ball up deep there's a great poet Steph
Curry done enough to be on the you know
same platform and I mean Mercy's
accomplished quite a bit that's what we
should remark about he said there's it
there's a play a remarkable player
called masala the king of Egypt plays
for Liverpool Football Club has had this
season of his lifetime 25 and Egyptian a
remarkable man plays in my hometown a
little ball in that in a deeply
Islamophobic Europe he has been publicly
an ashamedly celebratory of his Muslim
faith and the English have warmed to him
they're the local fans singing a chant
her they'd love to be Muslim too every
time he scores ago he's probably the
bulwark to Islamophobia in England right
now and I'm not exaggerating here's how
they sublime season what's amazing about
Ronaldo a messy two very different smell
test of how you view humanity is your
question which one would you prefer to
be Messi or Ronaldo indicate
he said the the the single greatest
season I've seen in a long time but
they've done it year after year in the
Jeter s kind of fashion they've just
brought it season in season out for as
long as we can kind of remember all the
way back to the Roman times when they
wrote ballads about such men
he's Roger Bennett the co-host of men
and Blazers on NBCSN what would you give
up to have Liverpool win well this
weekend the Champions League it's a
slightly complicated question I'm from
Liverpool which is soccer is like
Indiana High School basketball and
there's two teams in Liverpool then
Patrick there's two teams in Liverpool
this liver Everton and then there's the
New York Mets Everton do you hate
Everton or do disregard them
hi Everton my father was a never to
Union his father was a never to Nia
being an Everton Yin is like for me it's
it's like being Jewish it's like we
celebrate thousands of years of history
and the few happy moments it's life is
dark brutish and as an Everton fan and
deeply challenging but I wouldn't want
to live any other way because ultimately
that's life to me however having said
that you know I just was over with NBC
filming with Liverpool have a manager
who's called Jurgen Klopp one of the
greatest motivators one of the greatest
transformative leaders a serial
monogamist with clubs six seven years
too great here in them also yeah he
brought that to tombi went to the same
Shakespeare - yeah and he's open about
he's like yo why not do spinning and boy
he's like a Teutonic Care Bear he's like
a German Jim Harbaugh he's just that guy
who's just like oh and what watching
what he's done with that club with the
Boston Red Sox onus investing in a sage
fashion it's been a remarkable journey
and they're playing real Madrid who let
the New York Yankees I mean they are
always there three out of the last four
Champions leagues an amazing feat they
know how to win they've won
they've won knows it's gonna be a
phenomenal game but I even though I as
an Everton Ian I'm not a Liverpool fan
it's hard not to admire humanly humanly
what they've achieved under the Red Sox
owners
watch you know the Red Sox played Roma
in the semi-final Roma
owned by Jim pelota also a son of the
North End they should have played that
game in Fenway it's an amazing Amer
reckon achievement that two of the best
teams in Europe two of the best four
teams in Europe of both American own a
that should be talked about that should
be thought about and LeBron is part
owner he's good ownership right he is
that he is undoubtedly the goat Premier
League owner here there's never been a
better NBA player who is also the owner
of a Premier League team I think you and
about about as much of Liverpool as I
owned of Everton football he okay he is
a he is involved and what's funny cuz
he's such a Nike athlete and their New
Balance he keeps they have to make
special jerseys for him which they won't
have any logo on whatsoever and you
brought me a kit by the way okay that
the kit that men in Blazers kit and the
back your is your rallying cry not in
the face that is that's how hope for
American soccer for the next year it
showed the Jersey there it's a beautiful
obviously does its our men in Blazers
national team jersey were about to go on
the tour you asked about the World Cup
and the sad thing about America not
qualifying for me there's many sad
things you know I feel terrible for the
team the players who I love I feel
terrible for the fans who travel on mass
where that team now which didn't happen
in the 90s and they are incredibly
joyous and they're going to be deprived
of a World Cup motor I'm deprived sad
that we're all going to be deprived of
you the John Anthony Brooks moment at
last World Cup where America beat gone
in the last second than this huge German
American fell to his knees started
sobbing the World Cup before that Landon
Donovan breaking algerian hearts setting
americans just all the fluttering
barczyk we will be deprived those great
American moments but still the best
World Cups I had growing out we write
about this in our book but the ones
England didn't qualify for because you
don't have the sword of Damocles hanging
over you this World Cup is still gonna
be great we are gonna be touring across
America starting in st. Louis and
they're moving up and down the west
coast Los Angeles Seattle Portland with
Los Angeles this weekend Saturday with
the Mexican national team and we're
moving we're going Portland Seattle
we're moving into East Coast
Philadelphia Boston great authentic
remarkable American football strongholds
and this is the jersey that adidas
created you have one of a limited
edition there down it's the men in
Blazers national team we're going to
take paps he's going to be our central
holy there yeah you're gonna take him on
the road well FM on the midfield I can
work out well for you too by the way we
had we had a lot on yes on the show a
couple of weeks ago oh I can I can still
smell him faintly it smells it smells of
glory in here in the you one lot time
you get a lot done what do you think
whenever you guys been playing the great
the epic moment of the there's very few
black belts in several more this
happened oh this was over the weekend I
think with slaughter yesterday yes
yesterday yeah okay
so do we have the video there Paulie of
Zlatan can we can we show that when he
does the flop if you're oh yeah we'll
give us 30 second okay yeah yeah set
that up because this once again this is
what bothers Americans yes so here's a
lot Don and someone stepped some little
guy steps on his foot yeah look at this
synchronized this takes a lot of skill
to synchronize a rollover like that and
they both
collapse yes yeah that's that little guy
looks how much heavy do you yellow card
in that moment there I just give I'd
give style points for this rollover look
coordinated little role everybody's
light on is a bad dude I mean he's a
he's a big guy in black belt in several
martial arts that is everything that
Americans detest about football so
slatton is a remarkable football and I
wish we were looking at his goals from
his debut against LA FC which were some
of the fewest kind of water cooler
moments for soccer in this country of
the year that it will it will rank up
among some unbelievable goals that pass
the smell by test of the American soccer
curious who is our target audience of
our book you know the America is ready
now to engage with soccer those goals
were emphatic exclamation points that
really grabbed the Sports Center viewer
if anyone's still watching SportsCenter
Wow they also past the sell-by test of
Chastain people were everyone's watching
the Dan Patrick check thank you thank
God thank you right know that and they
passed the smell by test of the America
of the European soccer snob who looks at
MLS and expect his latin to bumble the
ball over the line with his shin they
were ecstatic goals and maybe if slat
unders dude there's nothing else he will
still become a legend in American soccer
but this
this to me I said it to you this is what
everybody in America hated about
European soccer in the 1980s when
Americans did not just not care about
soccer they actively hated and I hope we
get by I believe we've gone beyond that
down I hope we've got beyond what about
relegation in the United States with
that with that interest people if the
MLS had relegation mm-hmm
you expand a little bit and then you had
more at stake yep but it would it be
good or bad you're talking it say for
your sports fans that the concept of
relegation if you've watched Game of
Thrones you're familiar with the
moondoor where they just fling you out
into the end of the essentially how
European football works the bottom three
teams in it in the great greatest league
in the world if you're in the bottom
three can the end of the season you just
get flung out at the moon door and it's
a soccer concept and it's based upon
kind of soccer tradition and it's the
way the game is played in America where
these teams have had to have investors
come in and try and set up a league ex
nihilo they are ultimately incredibly
resistant to the notion of relegation
like you know we put in the money we're
not gonna voluntarily throw ourselves
off the ledge like lemmings it will not
happen for a long long time I'll tell
you every Premier League owner we have
and many of them are Americans we have
come over to America they watch em a
lesson like we need to do football like
they do it rather than them doing like
we do it so it would be it would be
there's so many strengths to relegation
there's so many strengths survival of
the fittest it's just not gonna happen
in America in the next decade he's the
man in blazer Roger Bennett the book is
encyclopedia blazer Tanika and smells of
aftershave and it's got a tweet cover
sport sport of the future since 1972
here in the United States soccer is you
can find men in Blazers TV show and
NBCSN the podcast on iTunes Spotify
SoundCloud in all major podcasting apps
Roger please tell Michael we sit alone I
will definitely do that and saying like
that Donnie baseball I will merican
Johnny baseball might be here as you get
ready to leave if you want to say hello
to Donnie baseball thanks for having us
thanks Roger
for more Dan Patrick
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]